alright guys what are we working on this
week you're joking right
what's problem I'm not doing what is
ASMR okay great how about another form
of sound torture Thanks music is a
universal language that's capable of
bringing people together and in eSports
you'll have a hard time finding a song
that's done that more effectively than
silver scrapes League of Legends fans
were first introduced to silver scrapes
at the season 2 World Championship when
riots and experienced running a major
international tournament caused nearly
endless technical delays that were
filled with this one utility late oh my
god this is too much but back then
viewers didn't realize they were
witnessing the birth of league of
legends new competitive anthem silver
scrapes predates season two worlds
though actually Solar scripts itself was
made in probably four days I did have a
deadline a very strict deadline but I
didn't have any money and I actually
wrote silver scripts a 10 year old
laptop
despite the out-of-date hardware he was
working with McCarthy turned out a true
a true masterpiece but silver scrapes
didn't find immediate fame the song was
originally uploaded by McCarthy to
killer tracks a pay to use music library
and surprisingly not a Thomas the Tank
Engine themed horror game
silver scrapes can still be found on
there too well if you search some of its
extremely baffling tags arousing
futuristic space adventure
what the hell anyway in 2012 right games
just happen to be using killer tracks
and during season two worlds when all
hell was breaking loose behind the
scenes someone left silver scrapes upon
the loop forever burning it into the
memories of fans waiting for the
technical delays to end I had some
friends that Burley glitches players and
they watched it and said oh my god did
your songs just on League of Legends for
like two hours and then I went and
looked on YouTube and I had silver
scrapes was up there for you know at
like five hundred thousand views and I
was like what this is crazy but silver
scrapes was destined to be more than
just a short-lived meme about riots
production crews [__] the bed the
song's popularity persisted and somehow
grew
[Music]
[Applause]
that was the worst [__] I ever heard in
my life over the years silver scrapes
has taken on an even deeper meaning for
league fans riot has taken the blasting
the track to hype them up at regional
playoffs and international events
whenever a series heads to a fifth game
and as a result it's become inseparably
tied to the competitive scenes history
to date our no one could have ever
anticipated that silver scrapes would
become the theme song for one of eSports
biggest games a riot happily embraced it
because they recognized just how
powerful music can be anthems unites
people under a common banner whether
they're ballads declaring national pride
unbreakable tribal traditions
[Applause]
or catalysts for amping up a crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
and although league fans don't seem that
interested in coming up with individual
team songs the simplicity and catchiness
of silver scrapes has made it a rallying
cry they can all get behind
it's even inspired all kinds of covers
from an impressively accurate version
played on floppy drives to mark Z's
brave but cringy vocal rendition to
whatever the hell this is
USC's Trojan marching band even has
their own version of it which riot has
made leagues log in music during the
annual collegiate championships well I
must admit it is kind of catchy
on one hand silver scrapes is remarkable
because it transformed from a torturous
production mistake into a trigger for
nostalgia a trigger riot is all too
happy to pull if it makes League fans go
nuts but on the other hand it's a
testament to the power of Stockholm
Syndrome
you've been convinced that the sound of
robots making fart noises is good music
and I'm here to tell you that it's not
too late you don't have to like silver
scrapes you don't have to get excited by
it it's a bad song
[Music]
he's talking about what happens when
this sheep allegedly allegedly it's the
same poor Diego with the [__] dog
isn't clunky yeah yeah don't even google
it it's a bad idea it's a bad time
everything's PG if you blur it out